[Music]
what are you talking
I wouldn't miss this for anything
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do this
I think I'm gonna like it here
I'll take
everything you needs in here
don't you just love a happy ending
let's follow my lead
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of titans young justice in this DC
Universe stuff to break down they
released a whole bunch of information
along with all this footage so you get
an idea for the other stuff besides the
TV shows and the movies that's gonna be
launching with it so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
I'll be sure to name a new winner at the
end of this biggest thing first they
confirmed that the service is launching
in beta in August with all the stuff
they included in this see how they put
Michelle Pfeiffer at the beginning of
this as Catwoman I love how they did
that because she's gonna be debuting as
the Janet Van Dyne wasp in ant-man and
the wasp all over the world in less than
a week so it's like oh hey yeah by the
way we have all this Batman movie stuff
that's gonna be launching with the
service and it just happens to be led by
this person that you're gonna be
watching in about a week pretty much all
the DC animated movies and most of the
TV shows they're gonna be launching with
this so if it wasn't clear all that
stuff should be available in the beta
but the launch dates for Titan season 1
Young Justice season 3 Swamp Thing Doom
Patrol are all a little bit different
than what I expected before what I
thought was originally going to happen
is is when they would launch the service
they would just launch day 1 with the
beginning of Titans and they would just
drop episodes until they finished airing
all thirteen then they would drop Young
Justice at the end of the year but now
with the news releases are saying is the
Titans will drop later this year in the
fall which makes it sound more like
September so it sounds like the beta
will be open in August for a couple
weeks then they'll drop Titans then that
will air for the rest of the year they
also said that Young Justice season 3 is
not premiering till next year so that
could be January that could be February
I don't think they're gonna sit on it
too long because the showrunner Greg
Weisman said that the show was
originally going to launch at the end of
this year so it sounds like they're just
trying to figure out the technology but
the actual TV shows like Young Justice
and Titans they're ready to go they're
probably just sitting on them so I'm
guessing the reason why they're doing a
Young Justice panel at Comic Con but
they're not going to be doing a Titans
panel as
far as we know is more of a technology
thing for the actual platform itself in
the app that they're trying to launch
then the actual shows themselves being
done because it sounds like for the most
part this stuff is already done now they
released extra synopsis for the details
of what's actually gonna be happening on
each of the TV shows so I'll read that
in a second but the big thing here is
they released like a full-blown look at
Britain Thwaites in his dick race and
Robin costume so you think of this is
like a jacked up version of his new 52
or rebirth costume now right now in the
comics obviously Dick Grayson is
Nightwing during the series he's gonna
transition to being Nightwing but during
rebirth day retcon the original Robin
costume just a little bit like every
time they redesign it just a little bit
so this looks just like the hardcore
version of that so you have to imagine
that this is right before he stops being
Robin and right before he becomes
Nightwing so that's why he looks so much
more jacked up and older than what a
normal Robin would look like you
remember that Jason Todd is gonna be on
the series we talked about him this is
like a behind the scenes look this isn't
actually what his costume was gonna look
like this is just him walking around the
set he looks like he's gonna be about 15
or 16 during season one so I'm guessing
he's still a year or two away from
becoming Red Hood or at least from dying
and then then bringing him back as Red
Hood the new preview that they have for
young justice season 3 is just more of
the lineup we've seen these characters
before you have Blue Beetle you have
Bart in his new Wally looking costume I
know there's a lot of questions about
Wally obviously they're gonna bring him
out of the Speed Force at some point but
remember there's 26 episodes in season 3
they says they're gonna try and run for
multiple more seasons so you have to
imagine that like 50 70 plus episodes
we'll probably see a big arc where they
try to bring Wally back standing next to
him is Tracy 13 she's a magic based
character standing next to her is arrow
it I know it kind of looks like red
arrow but I believe this is era wet then
obviously you have static in a brand new
costume
you have the cassie sandsmark wonder
girl we're actually gonna have Donna
Troy on the live-action Titans this is
what the actress looks like this is a
fan mock-up of what her costume might
look like too but then obviously you
have Tim Drake in his new costume and
then you have the Stephanie brown
spoiler good news is we have another
like
all blown young justice season 3 trailer
that's gonna drop at comic-con I'm
assuming that they're gonna post it
online like they're posting this stuff
online so whatever they end up dropping
I will totally do a video for no worries
I'll do a breakdown of their panel the
way they talk about the comics they're
gonna be unleashing on this Marvel
unlimited style is it'll be a curated
selection most of the pictures that they
showed were just like the really really
big titles so it sounds like we're just
getting the really good stuff then
they'll add to that over time but
they'll have a longer confirmed list
when we get closer to launch and all
that stuff will launch with the beta
what's happening later this year is
they're gonna be shooting the Doom
Patrol TV show I've already talked a
little bit about that it'll be a
spin-off of Titans they're trying to get
Kelsey Grammer to actually be the chief
so we might actually have a shot at a
Kelsey Grammer Doom Patrol series that
just sounds surreal just to think about
it Kelsey Grammer doing a DC television
show that's crazy
if Young Justice is premiering at the
beginning of next year it sounds like
Doom Patrol will launch right after that
in the spring then Swamp Thing probably
next summer
then Titan season 2 right after that you
get the idea like once series premieres
after the other one has finished its run
but here's the new synopsis that they
released for Titans and Young Justice
season 3 it says Titans will follow
young heroes like Robin and Rachel Roth
aka Raven a young girl possessed by a
strange darkness as they take on a
conspiracy to bring hell to earth which
is basically the terror of Trigon the
Church of blood brother blood trying to
bring Trigon to our universe so they can
consume it the same way you would see
like Dormammu during the Doctor Strange
movie if you're not a big comic book
reader Trigon is kind of like a Dormammu
type figure the ruler of different
dimensions the way he's allowed to enter
people's dimensions is by fathering a
child with someone from that dimension
the child serves is a mystical conduit
that opens the barrier between
dimensions for him he enters that
universe slowly consumes it takes it
over and then does it in another
universe so he just moves his way
through dimensions through the
multiverse doing that having one child
at a time so you can see why they're
sort of roping it off from the
arrowverse right now because they're not
ready to get into Trigon and Raven in
the air overs I'll talk about that in a
second too because people like are they
gonna put all the arrow verse shows on
this app but the new synopsis for young
justice season 3 says that they're
targeted by meta human trafficking and
an intergalactic arms race to gain
control of new super-powered use so it
sounds like new metas are manifesting
all over the planet and the light is
trying to take advantage of them by
collecting them all in the Titans or The
Outsiders as you want to think about
them because it's called Young Justice
outsiders are trying to prevent that
from happening they actually do have a
synopsis for that animated Harley Quinn
TV show it says that she and a bunch of
her cast-off friends are trying to earn
a seat on the Legion of Doom so the
whole series is Harley Quinn trying to
prove that she's badass enough to become
a member of the Legion of Doom they
confirmed that cyborg is gonna be a part
of the Doom Patrol TV series like I said
you know Kelsey Grammer might be a part
of that so Kelsey Grammer in the cyborg
character obviously it's a spinoff from
Titans so eventually cyborg would
probably join Titans in a future season
what I think is gonna happen with the
arrowverse TV shows is is that because
they are locked into streaming deals
with Netflix and a couple of other
portals right now to wait a little while
for that to expire then they'll put that
on the app to eventually I think the
idea is is that eventually all DC
content movies and television will go to
this app congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner David Noonan please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new winner
when I post new DC there's some new
Avengers for that I'll post later today
so that should be up in a couple hours
while you wait for everything click here
for my non-spoilery ant-man and the wasp
review and click here for brand new
flash season 5 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight